i couldn't help it i have a friend
okay it's time for some more election
green ticklers
and i'm gonna just tickle him right now
which one is this which
which board game does he represent
scrabble
oh okay
brain tickler did you know that andrew
jackson owned a parrot and taught it how
to swear
eventually the little guy was removed
from the president's funeral for
unflappingly
foul language by the way my kind of bird
i have a bird sunny i better get that
thing trained
brain tickler every president gets to
sign their own secret zip code hey
fun fact for the drew dear drew crowd
and
all presidential candidates get assigned
a secret service code name
for their families jfk was lancer
of course he was harry truman was
general
barbara bush was tranquility
john mccain was phoenix and kamala
harris's
pioneer you know if i were a president
i'd want my code name to be courtney
courtney
now courtney did you vote you know what
courtney
oh really wait you're stuck in the 80s
do you
age from the 80s or are you permanently
a child in the 80s or are you like
in your 40s i'm confused huh
courtney very odd oh what's that
oh right you voted for reagan i
understand i used to hang out with him
too
okay brain tickler in 1876
rutherford b hayes ran against samuel
tilden but it was so close
they didn't find out who won until the
following march
by the way i really appreciate that
everyone in the news is like stay
patient it's like such a really
wonderful thing for them to be saying
okay brain tickler andrew jackson
kept a large wheel of cheese at the
white house and this was a big
cheddar weighing about 1400 pounds and
the cheese was two feet deep
and four feet across and jackson served
it at a party
before he left office and when the
cheese was served there was a quote of
an exceedingly strong
smell so strong as to overpower a number
of
dandies and lots of days are called
ladies
hmm they don't like the cheese maybe
they should meet the turtle
and one last brain tickler how many
presidents were left-handed
kind of an insane amount listen to this
out of the last 15 presidents
seven are lefties that's 47 percent in
the global global population
only 10 percent are left-handed so 17
presidents percent of presidents 10
percent of the population they were
james garfield
herbert huber harry truman gerald ford
ronald reagan courtney
ronald was a lefty george h.w
bush bill clinton barack obama they're
all lefties and science has shown a
connection
between left-handedness and creativity
and lefties also benefit from
ambidextrous language processing
while righties only use the left side of
their brain to process
words this could explain why lefty
presidents can give such a killer
campaign speech
wow i've always wanted to be
ambidextrous i also want to speak
multiple languages there's so many
things i want to do
and those are your presidential brain
[Music]
ticklers